hello i'm tom insell and i'm delighted
to be able to welcome you to the last of
what has been a great series on
neuroscience from bio conference live
in an earlier presentation you heard
from bill newsom terry sinowski emery
brown and justin sanchez
about the scientific rationale for an
ambitious new program on the brain
in the next hour we will be
discussing the early plans for the brain
initiative with story landis from the
national institutes of health it's john
wingfield from the national science
foundation and justin sanchez from
darpa
for those of you who are new to this
initiative brain stands for brain
research through advancing innovative
neuro technologies this is a
us initiative as you probably know there
are
parallel and complementary initiatives
in the european union
china japan australia
israel and probably many others that we
expect to happen in the near future
what we'll be talking about today will
be that u.s initiative and we'd like to
um
remind you that what we've been involved
with here is really
capitalizing on a tremendous public
interest uh what we call sometimes the
brain buzz already in 2014
the brain has
been featured on the covers of national
geographic scientific american
and science news
suggesting that there is a great public
interest in trying to know more about
how the brain works both in health and
disease
as often happens in science the momentum
for this project in the scientific
community began with a meeting this was
a meeting held
now more than uh three years ago at
chichle hall in
england
where the allen institute for brain
science the conway foundation and the
gatsby charitable trust brought a group
of people together both neuroscientists
and engineers and neuro
nanotechnologists
to talk about where the opportunities
might be in an interdisciplinary effort
to
promote the next generation of tools for
neuroscience this led to a publication
out just about a year ago on the brain
activity map the brain activity map
became the
feature from this collective effort and
it was the
topic for a series of meetings that were
held throughout 2012 2013
leading ultimately
to what has been called the next great
american project we wanted you to hear a
little clip from the president's
announcement of this on april 2nd
2013 in the east room of the white house
now as humans we can identify
galaxies light years away we can study
particles smaller than atom but
we still haven't unlocked the mystery of
the three pounds of
matter
that sits between our ears
there's this enormous mystery
uh waiting to be
unlocked
and the brain initiative will change
that by giving scientists the tools they
need to get a dynamic picture
of the brain in action and better
understand how we think and how we learn
and how we remember
and that knowledge could be will be
transformative now importantly there
really are
two pieces
to this to the brain initiative that
you'll be hearing more about from the
subsequent speakers the first is to
accelerate development and the
application of new technologies i want
to stress that what the president just
said and what
each of the subsequent speakers will be
talking about
is the development of new tools tools
that will help us
to integrate neuronal and circuit
activity over time and space
in addition
it's important to recognize that while
we call this a neuroscience initiative
that many of the people who will be
involved will be coming from fields
maybe quite distant from neuroscience
today they may be working in physics or
engineering or informatics
nanotechnology as we saw before for the
brain
activity map
or other computational areas so that we
can begin to bring some of the best
science to thinking about the brain in
this interdisciplinary context
so what we're hoping here is that this
initiative will really serve as a
catalyst to make that happen
in the initial phase in 2014
uh there are three institutes or three
federal agencies that are committing
funds to the
launch of the brain initiative the
national institutes of health the
defense advanced research projects
agency and the national science
foundation
the fda will be joining us as well
although there's not yet a
fiscal initiative there we expect that
to happen and there may be other federal
agencies as well
importantly this is not just a
government project there are private
sector investments as well from the
howard hughes institute the kavli
foundation the allen institute for brain
science and recently the simon's
foundation and here again we expect to
see additional partners additional
private sector interests as the brain
initiative develops so in a sense we're
at a very early stage of this project
we wanted to start by letting you hear a
little bit from
each of the
federal agencies who are going to be
involved and i'm going to
start by introducing dr story landis
who is going to be telling you about the
efforts at the
nih
how
so as you've heard in several of the
other presentations in this series we've
made extraordinary advances in our
ability to understand brain function but
we're still limited in
understanding how the brain encodes
stores and retrieves information
so we're hoping we believe that we'll
acquire new levels of understanding
through the development of sophistic
sophisticated tools and technologies
that will allow us to assess
how the parts of the brain work together
to generate patterns of activity how
these patterns of activity are
translated into thoughts behaviors and
emotions and how experience alters the
brain's organization
now um i want to give you an example of
how the development of a new tool can
really transform understanding so in
2006 carl diceroth developed a research
tool that allowed neuroscientists
to turn on the activity of subsets of
brain cells or to turn it off with
pulses of light
hundreds of investigators now are using
this tool optogenetics to dissect how
neural circuits work
we've been able to define how deep brain
stimulation one of the tools that's used
to help parkinson's patients after
l-dopa is no longer effective
and and they've been able to understand
how the direct and indirect pathways
affect basal ganglia and parkinson's how
abnormal activity in the thalamus leads
to seizures after stroke
and how identification of a neural
circuit for fear memory so this one tool
has allowed neuroscientists to really
dissect circuits in a way that certainly
wasn't possible before
now the mih component of the brain
initiative
has um been
a research plan is being developed by a
working group of the advisory committee
to the director of nih
and they
will make their recommendations to this
advisory committee and what they've done
so far is to
consult with the scientific community to
hear what their thoughts are on what are
the tools that are required
they've made a preliminary report that
identified high priority areas for
funding in fy14 and they delivered that
report in september and based on that
report nih has issued six requests for
applications and the applications that
are solicited are due at the end of
march they'll be reviewed during the
summer and they'll be funded in
september
the committee's not done with its work
yet they have to develop a final a final
plan that will include timetables
milestones and the costs and they'll
produce that
in june of 2014.
now the plan will be implemented by the
mih neuroscience blueprint and i'll tell
you about that in a bit
so the high priority research areas that
they recommended are listed on this
slide you've already seen this slide in
previous talks and they include
developing a census of all the cell
types in the brain structural maps
very important new techniques for
recording from large numbers of neurons
and a suite of tools that would allow us
to manipulate circuits
advances on the optogenetics technique
for example
since the output of the brain is
behavior
one of the goals is to link neuronal
activity to behavior and also to
integrate theory modeling statistics and
computation
now the brain initiative is not limited
to experimental animals obviously the
long-term goal is to understand the
human brain so one of their high
priority areas was delineating
mechanisms that would allow us to do
even better imaging of the human brain
and also to create mechanisms that would
enable collection of human data
so um nih
released the request for applications um
the first two are actually focused at
the cellular level
and
the first one is aimed at
allowing investigators to develop
approaches for how you would classify
all the different cell types in the
brain
and then the second one ties the cell
types into the ability to manipulate
cell specific and circuit specific
processes in the brain
the next three are focused on circuit
level um trying to figure out how we
would develop new technologies and novel
approaches from recording not just from
tens of neurons or hundreds of neurons
but tens of thousands or millions of
neurons
and then how we could modulate that
activity
now we know that there are already um
technologies out there which
are almost ready for prime time and so
this the fourth and
request for applications
allows investigators who have begun to
develop something
um to actually optimize that technology
so many many people can use it
and then um
this the fifth in this
collection is to
begin to combine um what we've learned
about cell
cell types and how to manipulate them
with the techniques that we're going to
develop
for
reporting from big populations of
neurons
and then the last request for
applications is actually challenging the
research community to come up with a
whole new way next generation way
of imaging the human brain
magnetic resonance imaging has proved to
be an incredibly valuable technique but
the resolution isn't what we need and so
the goal here would be to challenge
investigators to create teams to do
something that's completely novel and
different
now the management of these applications
and of the projects when they're funded
is being done by the nih blueprint this
is a collection of institutes and
centers who fund neuroscience research
at nih
and in the past the blueprint has
focused on cross-cutting scientific
issues for example the human brain
connectome
we've developed resources for the
research community gensat
neuroscience information framework among
others we've coordinated research and
planning and we've developed training
programs so
this group of institutes has a track
record of being able to to run major
projects and it seemed
an optimal
mechanism for overseeing the brain
initiative
now as we look in summary um the goal
here is high impact and high quality
science the the requirement is that the
brain initiative must accelerate other
areas of neuroscience research
now overall the nih spends about 5.5
billion dollars a year on neuroscience
research and as tom has told you the
brain initiative is less than one
percent of that
so it really has to focus
yet at the same time have broad impact
and the goal will be to have tools that
enhance many areas of brain research
and that will develop methods for deeper
understanding of all brain disorders
and i think we we will be keeping in
mind that technology is not an end in
itself the goal will be fundamental
insights about the nervous system normal
nervous system function and also disease
and finally we wrote the request for
applications this time and anticipate
doing so in the future
so that we're posing the problems to the
scientists but we're not dictating the
solutions the goal will be
to allow the most compelling ideas and
and promising
potential ways of looking studying the
nervous system to flourish
and we will also be encouraging
collaboration
so
i will um turn this
over to justin sanchez
to do it next
order to john wingfield
thank you story and
hello everybody i'm delighted to have
the chance to
present to you today the
perspectives from the national science
foundation on
the brain
initiative and also cognitive science
neuroscience that we fund here at the
national science foundation at the
outset
i would just like to remind everybody
that the nsf
its mission is to fund fundamental
research
basic research rather than translational
research and in this regard the nsf role
and
here we go
is that we are uniquely positioned to
coordinate and lead all of the science
domains that we have here at the
national science foundation plus
engineering and education
to advance research development and
workforce education needed for the brain
initiative from neurotechnologies to
cognitive science
now um the basic research challenges
that are required to achieve the brain
initiative goals and which we are
beginning to focus in on
include
foundational knowledge about
neuroscience cognitive science in
general the tools for high resolution
measurements
these are the neuro technologies that
has already been mentioned
computational models and theoretical
frameworks data storage management and
analysis because as we all know the
amounts of data that will be generated
in the future are truly enormous
now to do this we are focusing in for
first of all on what we call
transformative research and potentially
transformative research and what we mean
by
okay so uh i'm picking up for john here
it sounds like he's having some
connectivity uh issues um let's just uh
switch over to the darpa perspective to
keep the ball uh rolling here um so
before i get started i'd just like to
say a few things this is a
remarkable
time right we have multiple government
agencies coming together and we have an
international focus and uh enthusiasm
and interest
in brain sciences and technology it's
absolutely just remarkable right it's a
extremely exciting you know once in a
lifetime kind of opportunity
to make a huge impact in this field and
um bringing representation up front from
darpa you know we're extremely excited
uh to be a part of this uh this effort
now um
one thing that i'd like to uh to to
share with the audience today is that uh
all of the agencies that are represented
here have a little bit different way of
of approaching this problem and uh you
know i would like to share with you
darpa's perspective
uh on how to um to make a huge impact in
neuroscience neurotechnology and and
deeper understanding of the brain so at
darpa um you know we think very deeply
about focused uh efforts that have a
meaningful impact on our constituents
and um for darpa it's really it's
military personnel who are our
constituents and you know we think uh
about the brain in a way that we call
the military brain right people that uh
you know put their uh you know their
lives in danger to protect our great
nation they are subject to extraordinary
con
types of conditions they include
controlling very complex systems for
complex missions
they are under extraordinary stress
where they have to carry out those
missions they have to learn some of the
most advanced technologies uh that are
available you know in the world and they
have to develop concepts to use those
technologies very effectively
and then ultimately
these military personnel are subject to
extraordinary injury right this is
life-changing kind of injury uh that um
you know in many cases affects their
nervous system and at darpa we think
that if we make impacts in in these
areas will not only help our military
personnel but we also uh make a big
impact in the broader aspects of society
if we can get some handle
on these areas
that knowledge and the technology
will have payback some
multi-fold
back to the broader
areas of society now specifically
speaking though about the technologies
that we think are going to be needed to
unlock many of the secrets of the brain
we feel that the approach
to really get there is rooted in the
convergence of technology
and just to illustrate this for you a
little bit
you know if we really want to expand
our insights into all of the
sub-circuits of the brain and how that
how those sub-circuits ultimately
contribute their activity to expression
of behavior and intent and interaction
with not only the body but the
environment you know we're going to need
some tools to do that and uh you know
having been a neuroscientist for for
many years now i can definitely
recognize that you know many of the
early advancements from darpa in terms
of revolutions and computing right
network computers
new kinds of uh computing power new
processors are were you know essential
for enabling
neurosciences and neural engineers and
technologists to handle right the vast
amounts of data that are that are coming
out of neural circuits right if you just
think if you want to record the activity
of let's say about a million neurons and
all of the
very detailed information from that
million of million neurons right that
the data streams are uh are
mind-boggling right so we need to have
computing systems that can handle all of
that now thinking a little bit forward
to the future right new insights from
neurotechnology let's say from the early
2000s there was a very big shift here at
darpa thinking from you know how do we
get the brain to do work towards how
does the brain work itself right
developing discovering tools for
monitoring these very fine finite
structures
at very high resolution and then
developing new applications powered by
neuroscience and with those new insights
to uh you know real time interfacing
with the brain i think that really opens
up
this next possibility of big data and
bioinformatics you know thinking 2010
beyond you know very collaborative
approaches
approaches that involve computational
mathematical statistical modeling to
describe biology
and to interface in real time with these
very rich dynamical systems use that
information an intelligent way and uh
understand not only uh you know how
those circuits are representing
information but how they express
ultimately their activity to impact the
organism as well as uh as the
environment
ultimately though darpa has a very
multi-disciplinary
approach to data processing mathematical
modeling novel interfaces to ultimately
produce new integrated understandings
and insights to the brain
now um i'd just like to you know again
while we're talking about very broad
perspectives and approaches uh for for
the brain initiative and and really
propelling
uh our uh our trajectory in this area
let's make a nice little a contrast here
and uh you know i really love this
contrast because it illustrates the
potential of where all of the uh the
government agencies could ultimately go
at darpa here we see a huge contrast
between the perspectives from the early
1900s which were very focused on
anatomic static kinds of maps
and what we want to do at darpa is move
away from that okay so we know the brain
is unlike any other organ uh in the body
right it's dynamical it's hierarchical
it adapts uh you know it changes with
this interaction with others and in the
environment even the body itself so this
concept of a map you know i think is is
kind of an old concept we need to kind
of revise uh how we perceive and
interact and uh and process information
from the brain now you know there a
great thing happened though early 1990s
you know to let's say 2013 there are
huge revolutions in fmri right that's
that's a step in the right direction
where investigators really try to see uh
you know widespread kind of system
activity and more in the functional
domain
uh to try to understand the brain so
again
looking at the brain from that
functional perspective but you know also
having the right resolution
and characteristics of activity from the
brain you know i think are also very
important that really moves us to that
right side of this chart here is that
you know thinking 2013 and beyond
we need to have real-time functional
measurement you know down from
say the single neuron or even molecular
level all the way up to you know across
multiple sub-circuits or systems of the
brain and connecting these measurements
with real-time behavior in a weight
behaving subjects understanding how
multiple complex behaviors you know uh
are represented in those circuits we
think that those are the keys to really
uh deepening our our knowledge and
understanding of not only fundamental
brain function but also remember
leveraging that to develop new therapies
for people that are subject to
extraordinary injury now with that being
said i'd just like to present the last
concept for you and give the audience a
little bit of an insight to our brain
function research portfolio so here at
darpa we're already off and running full
speed uh to try to develop and deliver
the most remarkable results back to
this great initiative and just to
highlight a few of those again for you
we have several categories where we're
making investments
we have a new neuroprosthetic research
going on in what we call the movement
and control category this is a project
called revolutionizing prosthetics many
of you have probably seen this you know
people that are paralyzed can be
connected to
neural interface systems that allow them
to think about moving and that neural
interface system can translate those uh
intent
uh into direct commands for a prosthetic
limb uh you know we have shown that we
can restore near natural upper extremity
control to people that have been subject
to extraordinary injury
you know we're pushing uh these initial
developments on and those uh motor neuro
prosthetics into uh you know very new
areas
of neuroscience and if we look at the
wedge on the top right there memory
recovery
uh we have a new program called
restoring active memory that
seeks to uh restore declarative kinds of
memories to people that have been
subject to traumatic brain injuries and
the idea is also uh you know very
interesting develop a neural prosthetic
that can sense from the brain interpret
those signals and then re-encode a
stimulation back to the brain to restore
those kinds of declarative memories you
know our foray into this area is going
to completely revolutionize uh how we
understand memory function uh as well as
development of new uh interfaces for the
brain
the third wedge i'd like to share with
you today is in this bottom left corner
behavior so as we start thinking about
more complicated functions of the brain
let's say those in the neuropsychiatric
domain
we know that multiple sub systems of the
brain are involved and this presents a
you know a whole new challenge
can we develop neural prosthetic or
neural interfaces neural interface
devices that can go to multiple
subcircuits simultaneously right so
traditionally neuroscience research is
very siloed people look at their
favorite part of the brain and try to
say a lot about that but as we move into
the more system-based perspective and
again especially in the neuropsychiatric
disorder
domain which affect you know millions of
americans and not only military
personnel there's some huge
computational neuroscience challenges
neural interface challenges therapeutic
challenges uh facing us so you know
we're trying to develop a neural
interface system that can treat uh and
address neuropsychiatric disorders in
real time in a closed-loop way in a very
precise manner so we're going to learn a
a tremendous amount
in this area of behavior
the last wedge i also just like to share
with the audience we always have an open
mind here at darpa we're looking for
extremely innovative ideas so you know
there's bound to be new investments in
the future in brain sciences
now the last concept uh just like to
share with you is that underlying all of
these functional investments are also
investments at darpa that uh support
understanding about plasticity and
adaptation and processing of data from
these uh these neural circuits
we recognize at darpa that to truly
understand brain function we have to be
very well aligned with the fundamental
processes of how the brain actually
works and we've made some new
investments in this area one in
particular is called neurofast neuro
function activity structure and
technology where we're going to be able
to capture with new optical techniques
um you know cell specificity uh activity
from large populations of neurons model
that activity and ultimately relate it
back to behavior so uh you know we we
really think that the culmination of all
of these projects in our portfolio are
really going to transform how we
understand the brain and how we develop
new therapies for uh people that have
been subject to extraordinary injury so
we're extremely excited we're working
extremely hard and we're looking for the
best ideas and scientists to to to take
their shot at this and deliver back to
the community uh you know some some some
transformative uh aspects uh of of the
brain so uh with that i'd like to uh
send it over to tom to provide some
additional thoughts
on the federal agencies that are working
in this area
thanks so much justin and story now we
have been having a little bit of uh
circuit problems of our own with uh
connecting to john wingfield at nsf that
may come up later in the
if so we'll go back to john
and have you be able to see the rest of
his presentation
but in the meantime we want to um begin
to look with you
at uh where we are in terms of questions
that have come in and uh have a chance
for both uh story and justin and john if
he's able to
return
provide some
answers to the things that are on your
minds
the first question i have here is any of
the fy 2014 brain initiative funding set
aside
for intramural research and
i think that probably is uh related
specifically to
the interests of nih so let me turn that
over to dr landis to respond
um so
some of the funds could be used to
support intramural research
when we um initiated thought about who
we wanted to have have the opportunity
to apply for this money for this
opportunity
what we decided was that we wanted the
best minds um
best scientists no matter where they
where they were doing their research in
this country and so uh intramural
investigators are permitted to apply for
this funds they will send in
applications the same way extramural
investigators will
and and they'll be re reviewed by the
same study section so the applications
will all be in by the end of march and
we are really excited to learn about the
people who've applied and the very
exciting ideas that they're going to
have
back
thanks story uh we want to see if we can
get back to john wingfield so i'm going
to
ask john if uh if he's on let's see if
we can
okay
okay
um
i apologize for the technical
hitches here but
i will try and continue
and as i mentioned before there's 20
million uh was assigned to the national
science foundation to uh cover
brain research and
this actually represents ongoing nsf
investments related to brain as part of
ongoing funding for research in
neuroscience and cognitive science
we quickly gathered input from a number
of our scientific communities on
priority research areas related to the
brain
and
we were also in addition to the 20
million we were able to support the
following
so we're going to
cut back over to the q a again i think
we're still having some technical
problems with
connecting to the national science
foundation our apologies but let's see
if we can get some additional questions
in here
can you elaborate more specifically on
nih nsf and darpa role in
interdisciplinary coordination
and
maybe what would be best
to save time is for me to try to give
you a quick answer to that
thus far while the projects are being
developed we've been
careful to make sure that
each of us has been involved in
the project development phase that is as
story mentioned there
have been these work group meetings from
the advisory council the director
across the united states on various
topics related to the brain initiative
and what we've seen happen is that nsf
and darpa serves
they attend each of those are part of
the conversation at the same time as
darpa has developed and nsf have
developed their projects
nih has been invited very much into that
conversation so
there is certainly coordination at the
project development stage
at this point we've been talking about
the opportunities for shared funding as
you probably know
nih and nsf have a history of doing that
as does nih and darpa we've had a number
of shared projects that have been very
successful on issues as
varied as with darpa developing tissues
on a chip to working with nsf nih
together with nsf has a computational
neuroscience program that's been very
successful with shared review and shared
funding over many many years so we're
thinking about that as an opportunity
going forward but we're still in the
very much in the planning phases and
it's important to remember
that as the president said in his
remarks this is a long-term effort we're
at the very beginning we want to be
careful about how we launch and
mindful about the opportunities for to
collaborate but also to play on the
expertise as justin said of each of the
agencies which is somewhat different and
mostly complementary
let me just check and see whether story
or justin has anything that they would
like to add to that
okay we'll move on to the next question
um
so
um
i don't have anything to add and tom if
you want to take the next question
thank you yeah so the next question on
here is would grant applications have to
provide preliminary data in order to be
considered for funding
i can take that from the nih and then
i'll ask justin to respond from darpa
as story mentioned at nih we have six
initiatives that are out there five of
the six do not require preliminary data
there is one which is an initiative
about optimizing tools for studying
circuits
and because that is about optimizing
current tools we would expect applicants
to have some data from the extant tool
that they want to optimize
and to be able to describe that in their
proposal but for the other five that's
not an issue let me check with justin
and we can find out at the time
yeah so um so this is a great question
you know at darpa we uh truly value
uh the the research idea and the concept
and uh you know that that's what we make
our investments in so so no we do not
require preliminary data uh for for our
projects uh if a uh if a a university or
a um you know a a research laboratory or
even uh somebody for from industry comes
to us with a terrific idea
and uh they uh they they show potential
for bringing that idea to life then then
yeah those projects can absolutely uh
you know take off uh again you know i
really want to stress this is about
innovation
and um you know finding people that are
extremely innovative and you know from
the darpa perspective you know willing
to uh take some risks in order to see if
that innovation would actually uh work
or not is something that we truly value
and cherish here at the agency so so
yeah not a requirement for us
i'm going to pass the uh the ball back
to
to tom
thanks very much justin the next
question here is
how do you plan to incorporate an
assessment of ethical implications of
neuroscience research
into the brain
or into the brain initiative and uh for
that i'm going to ask both justin and
story to respond on behalf of their
agencies i know they've
already often running on these questions
justin we'll go back to you and you can
start we'll go back to you
all right so this is a terrific question
um as we know as we as we learn uh new
concepts about the brain uh and we think
about new functions
uh about this uh related to this kind of
research that there are ethical legal
and social implications uh to this kind
of work and what we have done very early
was assemble a team of scientists uh
ethicists and external stakeholders to
provide feedback uh on the kinds of
science that is being developed and uh
again we we have interfaced with those
you know from the early concept phase of
our new investments all the way through
uh the um
the types of approaches that we are
looking at pushing forward and we are
going to continue to engage with them as
that research unfolds uh under all of
these projects uh so it's something that
we take extremely seriously and uh have
put a lot of effort and proactive
measures in place in order to do this in
the best way possible
thanks justin the story do you want to
respond about the
nih
sure
so
as part of the president's announcement
of the brain initiative
he included the engagement of the
president's commission on bioethics that
they would play a role as the initiative
rolled out
in looking at the ethical ethical
ramifications of any of the projects or
tools that were developed
in its initial phase we think it's
highly likely that
many if not most of the studies will
involve animal research and so
relevance of the bioethical
considerations for
human applications are not likely to be
that common
um clearly in the case of darpa where
the focus is on soldiers and veterans
they have needed to have um
a mechanism in place
to begin with i would say that nih has a
long history of looking at
ethic bioethical considerations and for
a number of human studies like
magnetic resonance imaging there have
been issues that have been addressed
related to
incidental findings in the imaging
and
everyone recognizes that when the human
genome project was begun there was a
percentage of the budget that was set
aside to look at
ethical legal and societal implications
so we are attentive to that issue but um
have not yet
found that there are particular projects
that require that kind of
assessment and i'll turn it back to tom
for the next question
thank you story i think
as you've heard this is an issue that
we've talked a lot about
um one of the things i think we've
learned is that we want to be able to
integrate the ethical legal social
questions with the science itself
we don't want to get too far out ahead
of ourselves we want to make sure that
the ethical questions we're asking
are actually
integrated with the scientific
opportunities that are there
there are a couple of questions that i
think are really terrific and we're not
going to have great answers to but it
would be good to these uh start this
discussion that are coming up the
first one
and and this is one that i think we can
all start to ponder what would be
reasonable to achieve within the first
five to ten years
it's important to think about
this initiative by contrast with the
human genome project which was really a
mapping exercise the human genome
project had a five year and a 10 year
plan with very clear deliverables and
milestones
measured by how much of the
three billion base pairs were actually
mapped
the brain initiative is quite different
from that doesn't have the same end game
and so this question about what will the
first five to ten years um
what will they produce
what the deliverables be i think is
really uh one that we're going to have
to wrestle with i'd love to invite both
story and justin
to give their uh thoughts about this at
this time recognizing that this is a
very much a moving target and the whole
hope with the brain initiative because
it's all about innovation and creation
of new technologies
is that
we don't get stuck in
what we're thinking about today so much
is to continue to be able to evolve as
opportunities arrive
so we would be very interested we would
expect at the end of five
five to seven years to have a very good
way of um
categorizing and identifying many of the
different populations in the human
populations of cells in the human brain
we would expect to be able to record
from
hundreds of thousands of neurons um
in the brains of experimental animals
and to be making significant progress
in coming up with better ways to track
activity in in the human brain
and we would
believe that we could at least in
experimental animals have additional
tools that would allow us to manipulate
to change activity in circuits and also
to
think about how they could be applied in
a non-invasive way
to human studies and uh justin if you'd
like to add to this
uh so so yeah i have a few thoughts on
this and so i would like to echo um some
of the things that tom also said so the
language you know was about milestones
right and uh deliverables and you know
those two words uh are words that are
very uh uh dear to us here at darpa you
know when we um you know take uh steps
forward on on projects we require all of
the people that work with us to engage
in in a contracting process where they
have to spell out all of these
milestones and deliverables
and those span across four or five years
of these kinds of projects and you know
we've already seen some concepts from
from from some really great groups where
people want to develop
new medical devices that could
potentially tap into these kind of
circuits
we are seeing some indications that
people would like to try to use these
new devices you know with human subjects
that are suffering from these extremely
uh debilitating uh uh situations
and uh so you know we're hopeful that uh
those devices will be developed in a
very uh a systematic kind of way in a
very uh thoughtful kind of way and that
they will ultimately uh you know uh
produce
um you know not only understanding about
the brain but also a therapeutic effect
and uh you know even if that is in um
you know uh you know uh specific areas
whether it's just memory or
neuropsychiatric domain or the motor
domain yeah i think
if any of those uh show promise
with with human subjects you know this
is a huge uh contribution uh back to our
understanding of the brain and uh and
and clinical practice as a whole so i'm
very optimistic uh but with that
optimism you know there's a lot of hard
work that's going to have to go into
you know
the neuroscience the neurotechnology
medical device development and then
ultimately delivery of such devices you
know on a much larger scale so we still
have a lot of work to do
so looking forward to that
passing the ball back
that's great i think you get a sense
from these answers that this is really
quite different from a moonshot it's
different from the human genome project
but it's no less ambitious it's actually
perhaps more ambitious
but
not with the
clear end game that you might want for
these other
great american projects as the president
described them
the next question on here is um
similar in character with it's what does
the panel see as the biggest funding
challenge
in 2014 and also long term
um maybe i'll start with that and then
we can hear from each of the panelists
uh and including i'm hoping that um
john wakefield may be able to join us
again if we can work out the
connectivity there um it's really
critical to realize that in the
president's announcement he was thinking
of something much more than what the
2014 budget looks like and there is in
fact the
uh an increase in 2015 in the
president's budget for the brain
initiative go from 100 million or 110
million to 200 million
in the president's budget i think for
all of us
we see this
uh in this case very parallel to what
happened to the human genome project
which started at about the same scale
and then continued to grow over several
years to become a much more
comprehensive and much more ambitious
effort
it's
i think true for each of the agencies
that what was put in in 2014 is that
sort of down payment it's a beginning of
what we hope to be a much larger project
and it's quite limited in terms of what
we can realistically deliver
in the case of nih with a 40 million
dollar commitment but i'm going to ask
my
panelists to also comment on this so
we'll uh maybe we can start with justin
and um
in terms of this question uh what do you
see as the biggest funding challenge in
2014
and beyond
so tom i i thought your answer uh what
was terrific um so you know i only have
a a few things uh just you know that
we're thinking about here so
uh you remember how we said that
you know at darpa it's all about
innovation and really you know giving
people a shot and uh you know thinking
that to 2014 you know i'm trying to to
really connect the available resources
to
the best researchers in our in our
country
and uh you know trying to mobilize those
resources very quickly uh to get those
laboratories up and running so that they
can uh deliver back uh these great
results that that we're talking about so
um you know it's it's about being very
nimble and it's about using uh resources
very effectively uh in order to bring
those results back
so uh with that um i can either pass
back to
story or tom
you see here
story your
sense about funding challenges
so i think based on the initial response
to the request for applications that we
saw
in the technical advice uh calls there
were hundreds of investigators who
called in each of the times that the nih
planned an opportunity for potential
applicants to speak with program staff
i think the biggest problem in 14 is
going to be that there will be many many
many outstanding
ideas and we'll only be able to fund a
small fraction of them um
that's been it's a general problem at
nih but i think with the excitement and
opportunity and need in this brain
initiative that it will be equally if
not more frustrating that the resources
that we'll have at least in this first
year
won't allow us to take full advantage of
the excitement and opportunity that the
scientific community is generating
thank you i i'd like to see if we can
get uh john wingfield back into this
conversation so john i'm gonna
conversation so john
okay i think we're still having
connectivity problems so we'll um
continue on with questions in this case
for um
story and justin and myself as possible
the next question on the list is
are foreign non-profits eligible to
apply for grants
and there's a second piece to that which
is only
partly connected i think are grants
given purely on the merit of the
proposal
uh can i ask a story if you'd like to
so the general
uh principle at mih is
that
foreign organizations foreign
institutions scientists can apply for
nih grants
but in order for them to be funded it
has to be very clear that they
have a resource or a tool or a
technology
that doesn't exist in the u.s so
so while foreign scientists will be able
to apply
they will have it will have to be clear
to the mih that they can do something
that can't be done in the us
and the grants will be given um
scores will be given to each of the
grants and
and and so that will measure the merit
we did have six requests for
applications and
i can imagine that
we would like to have
progress scientific progress projects
going on in all of those
so i think there will be an effort to
balance the um
the distribution of funds between those
six rfas so yes a merit will be
extremely important but if there
um
is
we will need to balance across the
several different areas
thanks story i'd i'd like to ask justin
to say something about whether foreign
nonprofits are eligible to apply for
darpa funding
so so yes uh foreign organizations are
able to apply for this uh so for the
community uh you know some great advice
is go check out the darpa solicitations
page that goes the main darpa website
look for under solicitations and that
website will take you to all of our open
uh calls uh for proposals and uh it
spells out very clearly there which
organizations uh can participate
uh it also in in those documents
includes the uh criteria that we look
for
especially on our projects related to
the brain initiative so actually the the
projects i described today they had
seven criteria and they range from
everything from scientific merit to
timeline to a cost realism
uh you know we looked at all of these
angles and there's one in particular
that was also uh you know very unique uh
related to the brain initiative we had a
review criteria that was focused around
data sharing uh so you know during this
discussion amongst all of the
organizations you know we really feel
that the brain should be studying a very
different way moving forward right that
you have synergy amongst the data sets
and uh you know synthesis amongst the
data sets uh can help propel us uh into
the future and uh in all of our new
projects we are contractually obligating
uh that the investigators you know
mobilize their data sets so that we can
get much more out of the investment in
these areas uh so something for you know
the more broad research uh community
think about you know the implications of
all of this and and how to do it the
right way you know how do we share data
and really learn the most about uh
neural uh recordings and and neural
studies and moving into the future
so passing the uh ball back to tom
thanks very much we've just got a couple
minutes left but there's one final
question that i think we need to address
what role can private industry play in
the brain initiative partnerships
collaborations etc the president talked
about this as an all hands on deck
effort
that meant both public and private how
will that work for nih how will it work
for darpa story
so there are a number of ways that
private industry can play a role in the
brain initiative um as tom has already
mentioned there are
private foundations which are
investing in this area
nih and i'm sure the nsf are very
interested in the possibility of
collaborations um or partnerships with
private industry
and one of the goals of the coming
several months is to begin to think
about
how best those
collaborations and partnerships can go
forward
uh so i really love this question
because um i've already seen some
spectacular things happening so we've
already you know received some proposals
on some of our projects and i've seen
academic institutions partnering up with
major medical device manufacturers and
then also partnering up with national
laboratories and again if you think
about you know this comment that
that tom also mentioned about this is an
all hands on deck you know this is
exactly the kinds of kinds of uh you
know response from the community that we
want to see
everybody's coming together to try to
get this job done uh in in the best way
possible and you know we've seen some
major players uh step up uh to try to uh
to take a shot at this so again i'm
extremely excited to see this enthusiasm
and i'm even more excited
to see what these uh new partnerships
can ultimately deliver back uh for for
the community so uh it's gonna going to
be interesting
well we've reached the top of the hour
and the end of the question list i
hope that if you do have additional
questions you will contact story or me
at the nih justin sanchez at darpa or
john winfield at the national science
foundation
uh our thanks to
the
bioconference live staff for helping us
to
present this conference sorry we had a
little bit of connectivity problems but
i hope this has been helpful to all of
you
to hear something from the funding side
of things about what the new brain
initiative looks like lots of excitement
here lots of opportunity we're going to
invite a broad community of not just
neuroscientists but scientists across
the spectrum to become part of this
initiative
that's the end of the conference for
this hour
we
welcome your further thoughts on this
and we want to thank you for your own
listening in and participation